[Musique]
une région épargnée par les combats mais
sur un pied de guerre l'otsc n'est qu'à
130 km du bélarus un voisin alliés de
l'ennemi russe
ici la menace est prise au sérieux voici
les dernières recrues du bataillon de
loubards des jeunes pour la plupart sans
expérience militaire on les sent nerveux
mais motivé déjà soudé par la guerre
unis devant la russie
des patriotes pas toujours bien équipée
et entraînée durant quelques semaines
avant d'être envoyé au front d'autres
resteront ici la base arrière doit aussi
être défendu il ya une autre raison pour
laquelle ces hommes s'entraînent c'est
que ce secteur de l'ukraine il est
stratégique pour les pays de l'otan qui
livrent des armes et du matériel
militaire ici une partie de césar ou
passe par la région et par les routes
qui sont ici
commandant rappelle que l'europe est
juste à côté
c'est par ici que l'aide étrangère peut
arriver à kiev le plus directement
possible
ce bataillon s'est formé en quelques
jours après l'invasion ses membres sont
prêtes à tout pour empêcher l'ukraine d'
être morcelée par la russie le
commandant promet que l'ennemi sera
anéanti sur le champ s'ils osent
franchir la frontière saoudienne
même confiance dans un hôtel de ville
bien gardée où nous reçoit un jeune mère
fatigué et très occupés spurs renard
nouveau retard pour une fois que les
défenses ont été installés les premiers
jours il est interdit de les montrer ce
sont des points de contrôle bien
surveillé parfois imposants le disque
compte huit mille volontaires en appui
aux soldats et policiers ukrainiens des
gens qui préfèrent souvent ne pas être
filmés ils sont tout de même bien
visible dans cette ville un peu comme
ces appels au patriotisme des rappelle
que les énergies doivent aller vers un
seul combat voce matinée stang mais le
maire reconnaît que la population est
inquiète angoisses et surtout après la
frappe de missiles russes cette semaine
qui a détruit des coûts pétroliers à ce
hangar c'est un théâtre les gens qui
travaillent si d'ordinaire l'ont
converti en centre de tri ont soit la
nourriture mais du matériel médical du
matériel militaire aussi toutes ces
choses là on les envoie directement au
front
ce midi on prépare le convoi pour me
coller une ville stratégique à 900 km
d'ici assiégés par les forces russes
génératrice drones de surveillance
munitions et médicaments vêtements
chauds tout un ravitaillement vital pour
entretenir la résistance ukrainien
le tout distribué grâce à une petite
armée de citoyens répartis un peu
partout en ukraine et précieuse
cargaison sont confiées et des
chauffeurs expérimentés parfois guidées
par des soldats d'ukrainiens pour
naviguer maisons les plus risqués
la ville de mario pol de mar
inaccessible à ce réseau un crève coeur
pour cette femme et son équipe des
artistes engagés toute une vie dévouée
au soutien de compatriotes offrant du
chaque semaine le cri de ralliement des
policiers résume ce qui doit être
l'esprit de tous par ici
armées russes crie-t-il
va te faire voir ici année du mot baron
radio canada l'otsc